good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is scp-630 one object
class Keter special containment
procedures extermination procedures for
SCP 631 are to remain in effect until
further notice
information regarding civilian
disappearances in scp-630 ones
environment urban and suburban areas of
the united states is to be monitored
with particular regard to areas outlined
in document 631 t disappearance is
related or believed to be related to SCP
631 are to be filter standard media
blackout procedures apply said incidents
are to be investigated promptly and
should an instance of scp-693 1 are in
foundation custody the instance must be
captured instead agents involved with
SCP 631 recovery or termination must be
supplied with thermal imaging equipment
mobile task forces nu 11 and Omicron 17
are to be regularly deployed to the
areas outlined in document 631 team the
airspace of these areas is to be
thoroughly examined via thermal imaging
or SCP 631 instances one instance of
scp-610 each cell the instance must be
restrained at all times and exposed to
artificial sunlight it is to remain
pacified by serum 631 gamma and
delivered sustenance by IV feeding
should the organism status deteriorate
one d-class personnel may be allotted
for scp-630 ones natural feeding and
reproduction activity all that produced
offsprings safe for one are to be
terminated and the remaining instance is
to be contained as instructed above
description scp-630 one is a species of
large predatory organisms with a vaguely
crustacean appearance they possess a
wing morphology consistent with the
order to europe terra and a reptilian
tail terminating in a venomous stinger
this tail also contains the majority of
the organisms reproductive systems
mature instances of scp-610 t'me ters in
length and 42 kilograms in mass scp-630
1 appear to be genderless scp-630 1 are
rendered imperceptible in the visual
spectrum when exposed to sunlight the
mechanism for this remains unidentified
however testing has revealed that this
response is triggered by heightened
levels of chala kalsa Farrell vitamin d3
in the organisms bloodstream scp-630 1
remain detectable by their heat
signature because of this it is known
that they remain almost entirely
airborne during daylight hours
scp-630 one do not sleep and remain
active at night furthermore they
demonstrate distress or panic in
response to low light environments this
reaction worsens in intensity over time
and it appears can only be alleviated by
immediate feeding or exposure to
daylight the organism will subsequently
locate the nearest isolated sleeping
human and impale the victims throat with
its stinger thus preventing any vocal
reaction following the injection of its
paralytic venom scp-630 one will remain
in this position for two to three
minutes while the victim expires then it
will quickly consume the victims
internal organs replacing them with
fertilized eggs produced by its tail ten
to fifteen minutes following the
reproductive act the original instance
of scp-610 fiying rapidly the eggs
require approximately one hour to hatch
at which point the newborn scp-630 one
will consume the remainder of the
victim's body after their post birth
feeding the instances will retreat to
secluded locations and begin their
growth period during which they are
inactive immature scp-630 one develop at
an extremely accelerated rate reaching
their adults size within roughly four
hours due to these factors the lifespan
of scp-630 one including birth feeding
reproduction and death can be as short
as 24 hours observation of scp-630 one's
behavior have revealed that they do not
eat during daylight and will only prey
upon sleeping and isolated human beings
in the absence of sustenance SCP 631 are
capable of surviving on average for 30
days
addendum 630 1-1 investigation and
findings scp-630 one has been traced to
a dr. Allen Forsyth and subsequently to
a facility owned by said individual the
investigation of this site determined
that it had been abandoned in 20 and no
personnel were discovered there in what
follows are excerpts of documents
recovered from the site rudimentary
biological systems are functional
circulatory respiratory reproductive
gastrointestinal still working on some
hiccups with neurological and n decree
subjects have stopped dying from their
own venom which is always a plus
through some pheromone manipulation
we've tailored them to instinctively
hunt homo sapien successfully but we've
in a very troublesome snag we can get
them to hunt the proper prey but can't
control how and when they do so
obviously this is a problem because we
can't have them flying around killing
people and broad daylight
electrolocation
is working miracles we can direct them
to subjects in a n REM or REM cerebral
state and some careful tinkering with
pheromone activity also predisposes them
toward isolated targets this should keep
them restricted to the right prey with a
roughly 4% margin of error we can't be
entirely sure who doesn't sleep outside
at night the project is nearly ready for
field testing but there is still one
crucial flaw we need to address
[Music]
solar camouflage is functioning
correctly but we're having significant
difficulty controlling their predatory
behavior due to necessary metabolic
alterations the adults have no urge to
feed in testing certain methods can be
used to force such a response but that
is impossible in the field the following
is handwritten and scrawled on a roughly
cut piece of paper fight our flight will
work but make it stronger produce
acetaldehyde so it should result in
something like a severe hangover with
that pheromone manipulation it should
equate physical pain with a desire to
procreate the rest is easy the following
is also handwritten but it appears to be
a formal letter your offer is accepted
the payment will be transferred upon
completion of the project those
miserable retrofits are going to destroy
any chance of my re-election if the
situation is not handled swiftly I don't
care what you have to do to take care of
it do it fingerprints on the letter are
consistent with dr. Forsythe
okay that about does it for today thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]